terrifying investigation into a random
attack of a woman in New Jersey her name
is Donna oshako she was Home Alone after
midnight this was 10 years ago when she
heard a noise by her door and she
assumed it was her cat went to check on
it but instead it was a teenager who
stabbed her multiple times Jim Axelrod
now looks at the search for her
attempted murderer and here's an early
look at his 48 Hours report
it was the Fourth of July weekend in
2013.
Shaco had just gone to bed when she
heard a noise downstairs by the front
door when she opened the door I saw
someone standing there
in the Split Second after seeing this
person on my porch I saw the knife a
young man pushed his way into her home
and began to stab Donna repeatedly I
felt like my legs were going to give out
so I braced myself against the corner of
my bathroom right next to the front door
before leaving with her car keys in
purse the assailant stabbed on a one
last time in her chest
I lost in total close to three quarters
of the blood in my body
there's no earthly reason why I'm alive
none Monmouth County detective Andrea
tazi she got upstairs and was able to
call 9-1-1
[Music]
he was probably about 17. White
real skinny curly hair blonde dirty
blonde hair it's a backpack a male
carrying a knife was spotted shortly
after the attack on security cameras at
a nearby shopping center we've done his
help a sketch of her assailant was soon
plastered around town
a tip would lead them to 16 year old
Brennan Doyle with a fresh haircut
investigators learned he normally wore
his hair long like this sketch
so that's a big red flag yes Doyle was
arrested and faced multiple charges
including attempted murder
his reason for the attack he blamed his
actions on being under the influence of
hallucinogenic mushrooms
Jim Alex joins us now what a story wow
brutal okay so he says he was on magic
mushrooms which is not saying I Didn't
Do It
um did prosecutors believe that as a
defense well it's interesting so he says
he's on hallucinogenics only he then
gets in the car he stole drives five
miles to a shopping center and has the
presence of mind to get rid of the
weapons so if he is on mushrooms he's
certainly thinking rationally for a guy
who's supposedly on hallucinogenics it
would be bad enough to do this to
someone you know but he had no tie to
her whatsoever nothing no connection no
tie and Gail the craziest part of this
whole thing well there's a lot of parts
yeah he's going to draw viewers interest
but she lost you heard her say she lost
three quarters here's another way to
look at it think about this the trauma
surgeon who saved her life said that
last of the 37 stabs right in the heart
yes Mr Heart by the edge of a dime how
was she able to survive then how does
this happen you know what watch tomorrow
night on
[Laughter]
the Survival Story is stunning cell
phones upstairs she's got to get there
how she got up those stairs
tomorrow night jeez Jim how is she doing
yeah doing it and dealing with her
trauma which you can imagine she started
uh her own non-profit to help people
that have been victims of random
violence she is a remarkable study in
resilience but you can imagine the scars
mental and physical and where's Mr man
is he Behind Bars he is for the time
being for the time being see you
tomorrow night I was gonna say you're
fighting us to believe that he could
possibly not be in jail I'm like that
there's a process Jim thank you very
much it's a heck of a tease you can see
full report a stabbing in Colt's neck on
48 hours tomorrow night at 10 9 Central
right here on CBS and Paramount Plus